Some of you might be familiar with the central Dallas symbol.
It's a symbol of dao and dao is a very strange word.
It doesn't have an easily translatable single meaning.
Um,
at least in English it means a variety of things that means the path of life.
So that would mean the,
the path that you take as you move forward through life,
but it would mean more also the proper path.
So it's that it's the proper path through life.
So the idea dow is a symbol of reality and one of the things that means is the
path you take through life.
And so there's an implicit idea there that the fundamental reality of life is
the path you take through life.
It's not a materialist idea.
It's a different kind of idea.
It's the idea that life is a journey while we're mobile creatures and we're on a
journey and know best way to conceptualize reality has as the place that you
journey through.
And the question is,
well,
what are the elements?
What are the constituent elements of the place that you journey through?
Cause that's also part of Dow.
And The Dallas believed that that's the Yin and Yang,
and Yin is the black serpent because those are two serpent's head to head that
make up the totality of the world.
And the black serpent is Yin and Yang is feminine.
Classically speaking,
from the Dallas perspective,
it's a symbolic representation.
It doesn't mean that women are Yin and that men,
men aren't.
It's not that.
It's an attempt to use sexual symbolism to represent a deeper underlying
reality.
And Yang is masculine in his dark and night.
And there's a white.in the black serpent and there's a black.in the white
serpent.
The white serpent is the daytime and masculinity,
and it's the interplay between those two things that make up reality and one can
transform into the other at any moment.
And so that's the Taoist idea of reality.
And so there's Yin and Yang and they make up the world.
And the question is perhaps act question is,
well,
what exactly does that mean?
Well,
it actually means something.
It's a kind of abstraction and it's actually an incredibly helpful abstraction.
Once you understand the abstraction,
it might be the most real abstraction there is.
So I'm going to lay out a little bit,
a layout for you,
a little bit about what these two domains refer to,
and then I'm going to make a case that they're real and then I'm going to tell
you what it means that they're real.
So you could think of Yin as chaos.
Now we need to know what chaos is now.
Chaos is what God made the world out of at the beginning of time.
So one of the things that chaos is,
is it's something like potential.
And so you can imagine,
and this is not how we think as modern people because we tend to think in a
materialist way,
but it is how we act.
And as I said already,
you act as if you confront potential and you treat potential as if it's real.
And if your attitude towards it confers on you a certain moral obligation,
which is why you know what people mean when they say you're not living up to
your potential.
No one ever says,
well,
what do you mean by potential?
Not unless they're being argumentative because you already know and very few
people say,
well,
I'm fully living up to my potential.
So you admit to the reality that undergirds that the conception that makes that
question of possibility immediately
the potential is while potential is the future.
That's part of it.
And we believe in the future.
We believe that it exists even though it isn't here and it's not measurable.
It's,
it only exists as a potential set of realizable possibilities.
That's what the future is.
And it's really what we contend with.
We don't really contend with the present precisely.
We Orient Ourselves towards the future and the future comes at us from every
direction and we,
we,
we decide as we encounter the future,
which parts of it we're going to interact with and how we're going to construct
the present and the past as a consequence of doing that.
And so part of chaos is potential and that's the positive part.
It's like if you're in a bind,
what you look for is potential.
Is there another way of conceptualizing this?
Do I have a different way of,
of acting?
Can I make another plan?
Is there something that I'm not taking into account that would make this
terrible situation tolerable?
That's all an attempt to to call upon potential and to use it to transfigure a
reality that's intolerable and maybe it's intolerable because of the way you're
conceptualizing it.
Now I'm not being naive about that.
I understand perfectly well that people can find themselves so badly cornered in
life that they're basically done no matter what they do.
People obviously develop fatal illnesses and they die and their businesses
collapse and genuinely terrible things can happen to you that aren't your fault,
that you can't fix.
I'm not saying that you can just gerrymander the world by changing your
attitude.
It's not that straight forward,
but I am saying that you have a tremendous ability to transform the landscape of
possibility that reveals itself in front of you and that when things are
terrible,
that's your best bet.
It doesn't mean it will succeed.
It just means you don't have a better option.
And so chaos,
that potential is also something that manifests itself in a terrible manner.
So imagine this,
this is a good way of thinking about it.
So imagine that you have an intimate relationship.
Let's let's say a marriage and the marriage predicated on trust and fidelity,
which is a variant of trust.
And that the trust and fidelity is an axiom of your memories.
You might think,
well,
what does that mean?
It's like,
well,
let's play it out.
Imagine you've been married for 10 years and then your wife tells you that she
has had three affairs,
each of them lasted three years and the last one has lasted five years and it's
still ongoing.
Or maybe you discover that,
okay,
so then you might say,
well,
what happens then?
Well,
what happens is that everything you thought was wrong,
right?
And this is such an interesting thing because it actually means you had the past
and you think the past is fixed.
It's done with.
That's why it's the past.
But all of a sudden you find out that one of the things that you thought about
the past,
and it happens to be a very important thing,
wasn't true at all.
And so what that means is that whole path that you thought was what it was,
wasn't what it was at all.
And so it transforms itself from an actuality into potential.
And most of that potential is negative unless you're relieved that your wife had
an affair.
Well,
but that's an important consideration because you know,
you can imagine a situation where your marriage is dreadfully unhappy and you're
just looking for an excuse to leave.
It's possible that that revelation,
even though it would be shocking,
would also come with a fair bit of relief.
And so this potent,
the potential that manifests itself,
even when it's unexpected,
it doesn't only necessarily manifest itself in a negative guys,
it can also free you,
you know,
and,
and if your marriage was unhappy,
even if you wanted to cling to it,
if your marriage wasn't happy and the betrayal was revealed and you're divorced
and you set yourself up in two years,
you might be in a better place than you were.
It's not a pathway I'm recommending,
by the way.
I'm just saying that it's more complicated than it looks.
That's the introduction of chaos into order.
Right?
And the,
the,
the oldest story we have is something like order is susceptible to disruption by
chaos and the human,
the d,
the fundamental demand that's made on the human being is to contend with the
chaos that disrupts order.
Not to live in order and not to live in chaos,
but to be able to contend with the chaos that disrupts order.
And so when you encourage your children,
for example,
what you're doing is encouraging them to become the masters of the chaos that
can disrupt order rather than Denisons of order,
which makes them tyrants or Denisons of chaos,
which makes them nihilistic and hopeless.
So you train your children,
you encourage your children and yourself and your partner if you have any sense
to be a master of emergent chaos and to be able to contend with.
And so,
so chaos has potential and it's this disruptive,
it's the capacity of the infinite world to disrupt your finite considerations.
That's another way of looking at it.
Another way of looking at it is it's the serpent in the garden of Eden.
And the reason that that story is set up the way it is is because it's trying to
represent that there's no place that's so bounded and secure,
even if it's set up by God himself that doesn't have an agent of chaos inside
it.
It's exactly the same idea that the Dallas put forward with their,
with their symbolic representation.
It's just portrayed in a different manner.
And the question is,
well,
what do you do in the garden given that there's a snake in it?
And the answer to that is something like you become the master of snakes and so,
and that's a deep idea.
That's the same idea as confronting the drag and then getting the treasure.
That's the same idea as going to the bottom of the ocean and rescue your father
from the belly of the whale.
It's the same idea and that's an element in the greatest of stories in the
greatest of stories is heroic,
heroic story.
And the heroic story is to voluntarily confront the unknown when it manifests
itself and together something of value as a consequence and to share it with the
community.
There isn't a story that's more emblematic of what it means to be human then
that that that is us.
That's our best bet.
Okay.
All right,
so chaos.
Chaos is the catastrophe that will suddenly enter your life.
Chaos is the flood that's definitely coming.
Chaos is the ever present possibility of apocalypse in your personal life,
in your familiar life and in this broader social life,
chaos is the consequence of your finite fragility existing in a world that's
beyond you.
Chaos is potential.
Chaos is what lies before you.
Chaos is what you can call on when you need something to rescue yourself from
malfunctioning order.
It's a permanent element of existence.
Chaos is what you don't know.
Chaos is what's outside the fire.
Chaos is what's outside the walls of your house.
Chaos is what's outside the walls of your town.
Chaos is what's outside of the borders of your country.
All of that is chaos and potential
order.
Order is where you are when what you're doing is working in the manner that you
intended.
Okay.
It's a very specific definition.
How do you know that you know what you're doing?
Well you don't because you don't know what you're doing because you don't know
everything.
Everything you do is bounded by ignorance while you still have to operate in the
world.
And so what you do is you make finite plans and the new execute plans and then
you execute strategies to,
to make those plans manifest themselves.
And if the plan's manifest themselves the way that you desired,
then you regard your knowledge as sufficient.
That's your definition of truth.
And it's the only definition of truth that you can use because you don't have
everything at hand.
And when you're aware what you're doing is working,
that's order and you might think,
well,
I should just stay there because that's a comfortable place to be.
And there's a certain amount of truth to that except for one thing.
If you've
defined a domain of order and you stand in it and you wait,
the disorder will enter all by itself because things aren't static.
Things change all the time.
And your attempt to bind yourself within a static structure is destined to fail
because everything around you is in flux.
And the thing that you've parceled out as permanent will transform itself across
time.
Here's an example.
Let's say you're a perfectly well adapted 11 year old and it's actually possible
to meet 11 year old children are often very delightful cause they're like adult
children,
they're not teenagers.
They're like as they're,
they're the most mature form of children and they can be really delightful
people.
And then like three years later you hate them.
And,
and the reason for that is that of course,
as soon as they hit puberty,
which is the emergence of chaos into the,
into the already developed childhood structured,
it's really the emergence of sexuality into a structure that didn't have to
adapt to sexuality and maybe even the emergence of aggression to some degree,
but mostly sexuality.
If the child maintains only the 11 year old personality,
by the time they're 16 they're no longer a delightful 11 year old.
There are very immature 16 year old.
And the reason that I'm pointing that out is because just because something
works for you now doesn't mean it's going to work for you five years from now.
And so in order to remain stable,
you can't be stagnant.
They're not the same thing.
Stability is a dynamic,
Nada,
not something static.
And so not only do you have to be where you are,
but you have to be going to where you're going and you have to be participating
in both of those things actively.
So it's stability plus transformation.
And I would say that manifests itself.
You know when you're there because that manifests itself as meaningful.
That's actually the,
the instinct of meaning,
which is an instinct.
And perhaps the deepest instinct is precisely the instinct that tells you when
where you are as sufficiently stable,
but you're transforming yourself at a sufficient rate to keep up with everything
that's changing.
And you know that because if you're at your job,
you might say to yourself,
well,
my job is really secure,
but it's not very challenging.
And you think,
well why do you care about that?
It's very secure and answer to that is,
well,
if it's not challenging,
it's,
it's deadening in a sense,
right?
The spirit goes out of it.
If it's not challenging,
you need to be challenged.
And why is that?
Well,
the answer is,
well,
tomorrow is coming and whoever you are now isn't enough for tomorrow.
And so today you also have to be preparing for tomorrow and next week and next
year.
And if your job isn't challenging than it isn't doing that for you,
and you find it deadening,
not meaningful.
And the reason for that is that it violates your most essential instinct.
And your most essential instinct is the instinct for meaning.
And it signifies that.
It actually signifies that you have the balance between chaos and order right
deeply.
Right?
Which is why it's the most fundamental of instincts,
because chaos in order are the most real of things.